a thought on breast cancer well I'm very
conscious that we've had some amazing
trailblazing women prepared to talk
about their own Journeys with cancer
it's so important check your breasts
know your body as the doctor just said
no what's unusual and different for you
but I think so important that we
continue Research into it particularly
when you look at the numbers of younger
women being impacted by it yeah indeed
so talk to me about
um home office figures that we've seen
in the papers this morning very much in
your area of expertise being told that
it's likely to cost the UK government
169 000 pounds per person to send people
to Rwanda
well these figures have come out from
the home office literally in the last 24
hours my committee's been looking at the
Asylum system over the course of the
last 18 months we haven't looked at the
value for money issue what we've been
looking at is the impact on women on
LGBT people and on children in the
Asylum system and what we think the
government needs to do to protect and
Safeguard children does that say I'll
come on to that but does that sound like
value for money 169 000 pounds per
person no I don't think it does and I
have always been concerned that the
Rwanda scheme is not only very difficult
to justify why we should be sending
Asylum Seekers to Rwanda to be processed
within the Rwandan Asylum system when
actually we should have better systems
set up here to do it but the value for
money question is a perfectly legitimate
and important one and it's worrying when
the home office themselves are saying
that they can't be certain that these
figures are accurate and they're all
predicated on the Rwandan scheme acting
as a deterrent and to date we've not
seen it act as a deterrent
what you've particularly been focusing
on is those that find themselves caught
up in the system how they're being
treated how they're being looked after
and what if anything we can do to make
that a more Humane process
so we looked particularly at pregnant
women who all too often are moved around
even in late stages of pregnancy or
shortly after they've given birth we had
sent to the home office that pregnant
women should only be moved after medical
advice has been taken but we're
particularly concerned that there should
be no moves to detain children as as
part of family groups and certainly some
of the government's new proposals are
not talking about excluding children
from the detention it's data not talking
about excluding children from the Rwanda
scheme you are suggesting that
potentially those that are caught up in
the system for now should get something
like 75 percent of the value of
Universal Credit that's not going to be
very popular with some aspects some
parts of the British public we took a
lot of evidence from people who are
currently in this country living within
the supported Asylum system who are
struggling to make ends meet is
struggling to afford basic toiletries
struggling to afford military products
and we were concerned that the figure
set by the home office for assistance
which has been recently increased to
about 45 pounds per week was simply
inadequate and a cost of living crisis
for women and for people with
disabilities to live on
you also were talking about children
there and you think that children should
be excluded from detention but the
counter argument to that is
um some who come over to this country uh
suggest that they are children they have
no papers to prove otherwise they
suggest that their children when
actually they are anything but so I
think there are two really important and
distinct issues here we as a country
have a duty under legislation to look
after children so whether children are
accompanied or on a company the
children's act applies and we should be
making sure that they're in school the
question as to age verification is a
really important one nobody wants the UK
Asylum system to be taken advantage of
so I'm very supportive of rigorous home
office checks on Asylum Seekers ages I
don't have a problem with that at all
but what my committee is saying when
children are children then they should
be looked after they should be
safeguarded they should be in school
they certainly should not be detained
but how can you tell the difference
between a 17 year old and a 24 year old
in some cases well I would always argue
that it's actually the kids in school
who identify the fastest when somebody
is the wrong age that to be in an
education setting and it's claiming to
be but I would say that that's the home
office's job it's not my committee's job
to determine how the home office
verifies people's ages they have a
variety of tools at their disposal they
need to be using them
talk to me more generally about politics
while I have you if you wouldn't mind
the home office been accused of leaving
people homeless by out bidding councils
in a competition for accommodation so
the home office wanting spaces for
Asylum Seekers rather than the councils
being able to put homeless people in
that accommodation so I think it's a
really important point is that we know
that the system is under enormous
pressure we know that there are tens of
thousands of people seeking to make the
channel Crossing in small boats which is
incredibly dangerous and is only putting
cash into the hands of people Smugglers
and organize crime gangs so their home
office is right to be working really
hard to try and Tackle those crime gangs
but when people are here we have to make
sure that they are housed decently and
there is a massive tension and you're
right to point it out between people who
might be on a local Authority waiting
list and the home office trying to find
places for Asylum Seekers and indeed
other sorts of supported housing so it's
never popular when for example the MOJ
is trying to put bail hostels into some
areas and there is a conflict there now
the solution to that and many people
don't find that any more attractive so
we need to be building more houses the
government has a really ambitious Target
around house building and and that has
to be the answer okay but where does
that leave us in the bidding war for now
what should the government do about it
well it's about allocation of scarce
resources as best you can and the
government needs to be working hand in
glove with those local authorities who
are trying to make sure that there is
provision for both it's a really hard
job to do okay it's good to see you as
always thanks very much indeed thank